bundle come on Oh Rapunzel you know her  name Thank You Kiki Bakugan coming to  Jersey channel one unforgettable nut my  heart will change the Rapunzel you know  oh yeah whoa what did you 70 feet if my  mother is going to kill me growing from  my head get ready for the new Disney  Channel original movie Tangled before  ever after when we want to do here Media  Bob just cut it oh there shouldn't be  any OH  oh darling Rapunzel Yugi yeah  and of course fine hair won't ask I'll  go back I'm sure there's a reasonable  explanation that you'll share when  you're ready thank you for understanding  oh come on really you gotta be here for  the hair-raising can't-miss movie event  angle before ever after the start of a  new theory angles coming to Disney  Channel  you